يعني عمليات البحث ما تزال مستمره في 300
موقع في اربع ولايات اغلب هذه المواقع هي
في هاتاي هنا وفي كهرمان مرعش وايضا في
اديمن في بعض المواقع وفي موقع وحيد في
ديار بكر هذه هي اخر احصائيه للمواقع التي
تنتشر فيها فرق البحث والانقاذ هذا الموقع
الذي وصلناه قبل دقائق فقط تم انتشال
ثلاثه اشخاص على قيد الحياه
وفي اثناء حديثك حول عمليه الانقاذ يعني
او انت تقول انك وصلت الى المدينه قبل
قليل يعني ما هي كيف كانت مشاهداتك
للاوضاع في البلاد
ما هي اوضاع النازحين في هذه المنطقه ايضا
المباني المنهاره المباني المتصدعه كيف
كانت مشاهدتك بصوره عامه
نعم حقيقه المشهد ماساوي في هاتاي مدينه
انطاكيا تقريبا شبه مدمره اذا لم نقل
مدمره بالكامل
الوضع ماساوي بشكل سيء جدا جدا معظم
المباني منهاره بشكل كبير عشرات المباني
متصدعه بشكل كبير وايه للسقوط وبحاجه الى
هدم سريع هناك المخيمات تقريبا
عشرات المخيمات التي شاهدناها في الاراضي
الزراعيه تم نشرها في الاراضي الزراعيه
قبل مدخل هاتاي والان هناك
جثه على ما يبدو الان سيتم انتشار الجثه
بعد انتشال ثلاثه اشخاص اخرين انتشروا
الان جثه من هذا الموقع كما نتابع معكم
تم انتشال جثه جديده من هذا الموقع
طيب هو المؤكد حتى الان انه تم انقاذ
ثلاثه اشخاص من تحت الانقاض في هذا المبنى
نعم ماذا عن
الجثث الان جثه واحده حتى الان هذا هو
المقصود حتى هذه اللحظه اليس كذلك
كما تشاهدون
فرح كبير لدى فريق الانقاذ الذي اتى من
قردستان هذا الشخص الذي استطاع الوصول الى
هذه الفتحه في الداخل وتم واخرج
العالقين ثلاثه تعاليقين على ما يبدو
انتهت عمليات البحث هنا في هذا الموقع
فعلا انتهت عمليات البحث في هذا الموقع
وتم انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص على قيد الحياه
نقلنا معكم هذه الاحداث عبر شاشه العربيه
ايضا انتشلوا جثه من تحت الانقاض
اذا ما زال هناك امل في اليوم الثالث عشر
وبعد 13 يوما
من وقوع هذه الكارثه ما زال هناك امل
بالعثور على اشخاص ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه في بقيه المواقع كما نشاهد الان
شخص اخر يستعدون
الناجي الثاني يستعدون لنقله الى المشفى
طيب نذكر ساده المشاهدين اذا كانه بحسن
مراسل العربيه فقد تم انقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص
حتى الان من تحت انقاذ هذا المبنى فيها
وذلك بعد ثلاثه عشر يوما من الزلزال وقد
تم ايضا قبل قليل اخراج جثه واحده ماذا
لدينا الان زيدان ماذا يحدث في هذه
اللحظات
نعم فريق الانقاذ انتهى من هذا الموقع
وغادر هذا المكان الان في الاسفل هناك
سيارات الاسعاف والفرق التدخل الطبي تحاول
اجراء الاسعافات الاوليه للاشخاص الاحياء
الذين كانوا على قيد الحياه
وكما تتابعون نحاول النزول المكان
نعم هناك جثه ما زالت حتى الان في هذا
المكان
وساعه الاسعاف تم التحرك تحرك اولى سيارات
الاسعاف لنقل احد الناجين الى
المشافي القريبه هنا